well today sky news has filmed rnli
boats bringing more migrants to shore in
dungeness in kent
we also witnessed these scenes in dover
where border force boats appear to be
carrying migrants earlier
sky correspondent iva bennett joins us
now from dungeness on the kent coast and
what has been happening there today iva
well in the last 30 minutes or so we've
witnessed some quite extraordinary
scenes uh really we've seen around 40
migrants getting off an rnli lifeboat
here at dungeness and then escorted up
the beach and and here they are now
waiting to be processed by immigration
staff border force officials uh they're
sat down outside the rnli um lifeboat
station on dungeness beach they have
only been here they've been on british
soil for just well 20 minutes and in
this group of around 40 i counted at
least
three children the youngest of whom was
a baby just 16 days old a c a
barely two week old
just over two week old baby girl and she
was brought
wrapped in a blue blanket to keep her
warm having been at sea since 5 00 a.m
this morning so that's nine hours
a treacherous crossing i asked the
mother um
why why they put their her life at risk
as well as her babies instead and she
said because it's her dream for her to
grow up here
um it's an incredibly treacherous
crossing but everyone i tried to speak
to not all of them speak english said
they're very happy to be here and again
reiterated those words that it's their
dream uh to be here and they and either
way they they knew they were risking
their life but the one man i spoke to
said um it was either that or reached
england those are the only two options
um he said he had most of them uh seem
to be from iraq and iran that's what
they told me
some of the men it's mostly men actually
on board well over 30 men a few women as
i say around three children
they said
well some of the men didn't even have
shoes a lot of them seemed very cold
many of them didn't have coats some of
them had
very wet legs so perhaps had been
dropped into the sea as they were
rescued by the lifeboats from whatever
life
whatever
vessel they had been in a lot of them
are crossing in um very flimsy dinghies
overlaid and underpowered all the way
from france is around 20 miles doesn't
sound very much but it's a treacherous
crossing uh crossing some of the busiest
shipping lanes in the world kind of like
trying to walk across a an eight-lane
motorway it's incredibly dangerous
and this follows a period of
increased crossings that sky news
witnessed yesterday our team
on the french side of the channel
witnessed a fleet of crossings
being uh launched from uh the french
side normally they leave under the cover
of darkness but this time yesterday it
was in daylight and it was under the
gaze of the french authorities who did
nothing it appears to try and stop them
and that was again borne out today the
one man i spoke to who has just arrived
here in britain off this lifeboat at
dungeness told me that the french
authorities were watching
as they left the french beach and they
did again they did nothing uh to stop
them that is uh the words of one man
who's just arrived here as he's waiting
to process by immigration staff this
uh the latest arrivals to to come across
the channel it takes the numbers well
above 1700 from the start of the year
and that is more than double
more than double uh the total number of
migrants that cross the channel from
france to britain
for last year it is uh something that
pretty patel the home secretary has said
she will crack down on
repeatedly including
uh as recently as just this week at the
conservative party conference but uh
clearly the migrants keep coming it is a
period of relatively calm weather this
is generally considered the last window
of opportunity for anyone who wants to
cross the channel to do so before the
end of the the year
and clearly they are seizing that
opportunity
um with both hands
and as i say it is a problem for the
for the government a political problem
that it seems to be well not going away
at all